what is one color you would never dye
your hair great you could go back in
time to any moment in playoff history
what would it be I'm not gonna lie I
always wanted to be the shot that
Brandon Roy hit Portland series when uh
Brandon Roy hits the game winner that
Dame recreated a couple years later so
you're watching One TV show TV show for
the rest of your life Law and Order SVU
that's my favorite ah what about a
favorite artist Michael Jackson what's
your go-to MJ song My Favorite Michael
Jackson song rock my world so you're
from Texas who is your number one
all-time Texas athlete does it have to
just be basketball no any sport oh oh
that makes it even tougher I'm gonna go
Chris Bosh if you weren't playing in the
NBA what would your dream job be
probably be a gymnast okay all right
here's trick shot time we're on last
question all right I'm gonna go with my
favorite trick shot
close I usually take one to line it up
two to knock it down
oh close